want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know you've got something more
inside you two you have michael jordan
level genius at something so today let's
live your best believe life and learn
how billionaires think and get some
success advice from the top
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with advice
number one listen to the whispers with
oprah winfrey you see your life whispers
to you all the time if you're paying
attention from the moment you open your
eyes in the morning until the moment you
go to bed at night it's just speaking to
you and really hearing those whispers is
one of the most integral pieces of the
puzzle i believe that's needed to put
together the bigger picture
of your best life now there might be a
message sent or meant for you that first
comes in a whisper that to you sounds
like hmm
that's strange or hmm that seems odd i
didn't leave that door open but then if
that whisper isn't a dress the whisper
will become amplified getting louder and
louder until it suddenly becomes what i
call a big thump on your head and if
you're still not paying attention that
little nudge transforms into a brick of
a problem and then eventually all of
those ignored bricks that make up the
structure and stability of your life
come crashing down so
know this for sure life is whispering to
you all the time
then turns into a brick of a problem you
ignore that problem you get a brick wall
of crises so the key is
learning to get the whispers before they
turn into bricks
so
this has shown up most often in my life
through relationships bad relationships
when i was younger when someone who's
shown me who they are in a whisper and i
keep hanging on until they do something
that's like a brick upside my head
so last year listen to this i toured for
wwe from january 4th to march 8th and
immediately after that last show i went
to the bahamas to take a week's break
and after two days i started feeling the
strong whisper just a feeling that maybe
i shouldn't be relaxing
in foreign waters and should get home
in case
our country went into some kind of
shutdown
literally at three in the morning that
feeling came over me
that i need to leave i need to get home
so
i returned home on march 11th stayed in
lockdown for the next 321 days
and i've learned over the years to kind
of pay attention and heed what twister
bring before it has to knock me upside
the head
so many things in life
like the pandemic are out of our control
but i do know that many things are in
our control unless you choose to
sleepwalk your way through it so i ask
you what is whispering to you right now
some of you may have realized the life
you live before the pandemic no longer
actually serves you and that returning
to working in an office is not your next
best move or maybe you gained a deeper
appreciation for your family and friends
or alone time as we talked about last
week you might even have turned a
passion or hobby into a full-on business
but there are others who are just gonna
get right back to their routine without
heaving those whispers and understanding
what is really calling to you if there's
one message you take away from me today
it's to listen to the whispers
because you are in the driver's seat as
to where
they leave you
so for the 25 years that i did the oprah
show i would often get frustrated
because some guests who would come back
and they just weren't paying attention
to their life
but i realized too it's easier to
observe it
it's often much easier to observe
someone else's situation more clearly
than your own so i encourage you to take
the time to observe and listen
become aware and learn to discern what
your head is saying versus what your
heart
is saying and sometimes you may follow a
voice in your head that's not your true
calling and that's okay too because you
get as much from the losses as you do
from the winds so i say
just keep
listening
being aware
of what is whispering to you now
advice number two
display exceptional ability with elon
musk just look for
evidence of exceptional ability
so it's not
at least aspirationally like sometimes
these things get
messed up in
recruiting or the recruiting photo
beings ends up being wrong like i
sometimes wonder with tesla
if nikola tesla applied to tesla would
we even give him an interview
it's not clear
you know this guy came from like some
weird college and
somewhere in eastern europe i think he's
got some odd mannerisms now we don't
know if we should give an interview like
i i worry that that's actually what we
do instead of like
it should be like man [ __ ] this this
this kid's super smart
what does he want we'll pay him anything
that should be that that should be the
reaction if nikola tesla applies you
know to tesla um ironically
but so i can tell you the intent is
we're looking for evidence of
exceptional ability uh and it really
doesn't matter if you're wanting to
graduate high school or college or
anything we're just looking for evidence
of exceptional ability uh such that it
would be a good predictor for doing
exceptional things spacex advice number
three find clarity it's hard to have
conviction about whether something will
work and the only thing that i can
offer
every once in a while you get this a
crisp moment of clarity where you just
know some things are going to work
if you are persistent enough and those i
think you can only do that if you start
with the customer and work backwards i
don't think you can build that kind of
clarity on what your competitors are
doing or what kinds of technologies are
available in the marketplace it can only
that kind of clarity can only come from
a deep understanding of customer needs
and the good thing about customer needs
is they
change slowly in time so you can count
on them i know for a fact
that 10 years from now
amazon's customers will still want low
prices
i know for a fact that amazon's
customers 10 years from now will still
want fast delivery
they'll still want vast selection and
it's there's no chance that 10 years
from now somebody will come to me and
say jeff i love amazon i just wish you
delivered a little more slowly
so because those customer needs are so
foundational sometimes around those
things you can get real clarity and then
you can invest
and you can know that your investments
will pay dividends for customers over
time
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there advice number four match ideas
with intention with bill gates i
remember one great fear i had
when we did microsoft research was that
the
if we weren't careful it'd be
a block to our view of what was going on
in the academic community that is we
would hire somebody who had an approach
and that academia as a whole would have
like 20 approaches you know a number of
which would likely be better than some
internal approach and so i wanted
somebody who was open-minded enough to
say no the you know this group here
uh is doing it the right way
uh and i was worried would that fluidity
exist so a lot of these programs like
having students come here like the
faculty summit have contributed to the
idea that okay we're part of a broader
committee community
we publish great things you know people
come and go
a lot so i feel super good about that
in terms of work uh
you know i would say the most of the
opportunity to make computers improve
work is in front of us instead of behind
us
only at kind of a very mechanical level
of
uh it's better than whiteout
uh
you know are we like oh wow this thing
helps me get my work done
for extremely structured tasks like
creating financial statements you know
where the application logic is very
opaque and you're just led through it or
for very horizontal things where you
really understand what you're up to and
the machine doesn't see
oh that emails part of personnel review
that email's part of planning the uh the
salesforce meeting so we have kind of
the the low-level horizontal which in
this way is
amazing and then we have this very
structured applications world the idea
of of
matching
what you and your head have is the
intention of the overall activity in the
semantics around it
and therefore sort of maximally helping
you with those things i think now
that a lot of base level things are
are done very well including gathering
the data and learning from it that we
should be able to
have what the machine thinks you're up
to and what you think you're up to match
each other
uh and
improve the productivity quality quality
quite dramatically advice number five
grind it out with mark cuban don't stop
looking for a job now
right just because things are difficult
doesn't mean you know that there's not
opportunity there because all it takes
is one
if you just if if you grind it out and
you continue to be persistent whether
it's emailing calling you know setting
up on seminars whatever it may be
however you can connect with people
applying for jobs to wherever however do
it you know every node gets you closer
to a yes and all it takes is that one
opportunity to propel you to where you
look to be
and you know and i guess adding to that
again like i said earlier there there's
so many new things going on when you
know when i came out of college way back
when um the was the last time that
unemployment was in double digits you
know my friends you know i remember
reading a story i went to indiana
university talking about how the
unemployment rate in northern indiana
was 20
and you know my friends were freaked out
like kids are today and i had to be
mobile right i had to go from indiana
back to pittsburgh my home down to
dallas in order to really get to a job
that that i could platform and so as you
look for these things
you you really have to be more
adventurous if you will and be more
mobile and be more flexible and agile
and and that's not necessarily a bad
thing you don't have to get the best job
you don't have to get a perfect job you
just have to get a job and now all of a
sudden you're getting paid to learn and
you can platform that just like an mba
free agent right they might spend one
year or two year at one two years at one
team build their skill set to get better
and go to a better situation looking and
finding a job looking and finding an
internship looking at building your
skill set to prepare yourself for what
comes next
there's no better opportunity than now
advice number six build a great team
with vinod khosla building a team is the
hardest thing for an entrepreneur to do
because very often they don't know what
they don't know
right they they know their area of
specialty really well
but other areas they think they
understand but they don't and every area
is more complex and more nuanced than it
appears to somebody you know to i see so
many entrepreneurs who think marketing
is about a press release or an
advertising campaign it's not
it's much more nuanced and sophisticated
than that so team building is very
important
some entrepreneurs do a really good job
of growing larry page is an example mark
zuckerberg is an example of
being better at new functions as they
come up
uh
ins and and and also they've done a
really good job of adding people who
they can learn these new areas from
uh what i find is some entrepreneurs
assume they know the answer
and that's very dangerous and others
know they don't know
and they hire the people who they can
learn from
but they can still apply their
entrepreneurial style in these new areas
sometimes it makes sense for the
entrepreneur to keep being ceo and
driving the whole vision usually that's
the best course but some entrepreneurs
can't think broadly enough to do that
and they can't grow fast enough and
advice number seven the last one before
some very special bonus clips is keep
attacking with grant cardone there was
this book written called uh the
millionaire next door it was a big
sensation too a lot of people read this
book it was a super super hit big hit
book okay and when i read the book i was
like
i got something different from it than
what other people got from it other
people were like okay i'm not i'm not
going to coffee shops anymore okay i'm
not going to buy a brand new car anymore
what i got was
i don't want to be the millionaire next
door
that's what i got from the book so it's
all about your viewpoint right when when
i finished reading the book i was like
okay i don't want to be a millionaire
and i'm definitely not going to take
advice from a millionaire because when
you get a million dollars if you if you
came from if you came up the way you and
i did and you had nothing i give you a
million dollars and you're gonna think
dude
oh my god i've got a million dollars
your mom's gonna kiss you oh he's done i
always knew you could make it right
and then and then and then you're gonna
wake up the next morning and say dude i
don't want to lose this money
you go into conservation into defense
you start playing defense
i was with mike tyson i did mike tyson's
podcast the boxer right well in 19 years
old mike was a champion of the world
yeah
when mike got in the ring man
in in when he was at his
perfection
he didn't hit you once he hit you and he
kept hitting you until you went down
there was
attack attack attack attack attack
attack attacking two you couldn't get up
two you're like you're just gonna even
if the body can get up you're like i
don't want to get up now because i can't
win this
and that is the way people should be
attacking life right
when mike started getting data i even
told him this i said dude when you went
to the therapist when you started
therapy is when you started having
problems
grant you're right grant
queen you're right when you stop seeing
the therapist you got better because the
therapist puts you on defense what are
you doing
you start going on defense you start
looking at where you made your mistakes
as opposed to saying hey dude what
worked let's repeat it
let's don't do destructive stuff yeah
let's get rid of whatever's driving the
destructive behavior right but
with money man with money what you want
to do is you want to double down yeah
this is why the casinos never never you
know get broke because nobody bets
enough in the casinos if all the whales
showed up
in macau yeah or in in right here in
london or or in vegas and all the whales
showed up at one weekend and said hey
we're gonna break the bank and we're
gonna all push in hard they could take
down the casino but because all the
little guys go to the bank they they
lose five they lose five they lose five
they win fifteen they say i'm out of
here yeah okay if they break even they
think they had a big night
it's all in the mindset
when you get up in the morning you do
what you normally do
i would eventually a lot of you here
probably turn on your cell phones your
computers and what's the latest email
what's the latest text that comes in you
start your day off like that
that's your mindset
try this
get up in the morning do whatever you
have to do don't turn the computer on
don't turn the tv on go right back to
bed again either lay there or sit there
and just bring the universe to you
here's how you do it
you just be
it's virtually impossible when you first
do it because a thousand thoughts come
through your head we're human beings so
what you do is you're sitting in bed
look at the wall look at the off tv set
look at the ceiling look at the door
look at something in the room that gets
your attention
and just look at it and just be for a
couple minutes not 10 minutes not 20
minutes not two days just be when your
mind wanders find another spot in the
room to look at so you're back in
present time even for a couple of
minutes
now go about your day don't think about
what you're going to do for that split
few minutes you're now becoming part of
a universe which is also part of global
thinking so of all the things in the
world that you could say are like the
secrets that being positive is one of
the
main things that people need to do how
did you happen on that in life
whether it's personal or people around
me when you see people that are positive
that look at something good and
something bad that took place they move
along in life faster they're better and
people want to be around these people i
mean too often people gossip the one
gossip person wants to be around the
other person that gossips but they don't
realize
when you gossip you're saying something
you heard about somebody else you're
telling everybody what if part of it was
wrong you're gonna go out and tell every
person you told this oh i'm sorry it was
wrong tell everybody you told it's not
gonna happen so it seems to learn about
don't gossip don't build little people
if you don't have to god please don't
try and look at the positive angle what
good could come out of something and
that positiveness is going to make you
live longer
happier and wake up in the morning happy
not oh my god i gotta go to work i can't
wait till i get home i want to retire
because people were not positive they
were not happy and what happens if they
retire they hate their job they retire
three or four years later they're dead
because they have nothing to do that
positive attitude be around positive
people
encourage positiveness if you find
yourself walking around just complaining
all the time around people that complain
a lot man move or just try and do
something different change your life
being positive and a positive attitude
is find something positive and something
bad
makes you look for solutions when i was
down and out okay oh pop bottles let's
get the pop bottles cash them in i had
one habit that uh i developed when i
when i was
at college that was actually a very bad
habit which was
i like to show people that i didn't do
any work uh and that i didn't go to
classes and i didn't care and then at
the very last minute uh like two days
before the test i get serious about it
and and people
people thought that was funny uh you
know that was my positioning the guy who
did nothing until the last minute then
when i went into business that was a
really bad habit
and it took me a couple years to get
over that nobody praised me because i i
would do things at the last minute and
and i tried to reverse uh to students
i'd actually uh i didn't think that
highly of who were always organized and
had things done on time i'm still
working on it but uh
procrastination is not a good good habit
and what about steve jobs in those days
what was your relationship with him uh
in the early days and how did it change
well we were both there at the very
beginning
the
apple one was a kick computer that steve
wozniak
designed and he worked with steve and
they came and offered it at various of
these computer club meetings and we went
to lots of computer club meetings so we
were sort of colleagues and pitching the
gospel of
uh personal computing we were kind of
competitors
the
the time we were together most intensely
was after the ibm pc came out steve had
a group actually a small group at apple
that was doing the macintosh and he came
to us early on
and asked us if we'd commit resources we
actually put more people on the project
than apple did and did
the early application software that used
that mouse
graphics interface and so it was a huge
win both for microsoft and for apple
when the macintosh became so successful
you don't have to hold yourself hostage
to who you used to be or anything you
ever used to do
because who has lived and hasn't made
mistakes when i think about my twenties
and what a foolish girl i was and how
i would
give over my power to men who
really didn't mean me well but now i
hold no grudges against them either
because i realize i'm the one who gave
over the power because i didn't know any
better and now that i know better i know
i don't have to do that again it's one
of the most powerful lessons any of us
can ever know i say to the my girls
all of the time that your real work
is to figure out
where your power base is
and to work on the alignment of your
personality your gifts that you have to
give with the real reason why you're
here that's that's the number one thing
you have to do
is to work on yourself and to fill your
self
up
and keep your cup full keep yourself
full now i used to be afraid of that
i used to be afraid particularly from
people who say oh she said she's still
fella
she's so close herself and now
i embrace it
i i consider it a compliment that i am
full
of myself
because you only when you're full i'm
full i'm overflowing my cup run it's
over
i have so much i have so much to offer
and so much to give and i am not afraid
of honoring myself you know it's
miraculous when you think about it i was
very very bookish i was reading all the
time so i was either reading
working my computer
reading comics playing dungeon dragons
that kind of thing
i understand hitchhiker's guide to the
galaxy that wonderful book by douglas
adams that was a that was a key book for
you
what was it about that book that fired
your imagination um yeah so
uh i guess when i was
in uh around 12 or 13 i had a company
existential crisis and i was reading
various books
um
on trying to figure out the meaning of
life and well like what does it all mean
because
uh it
starts seeming quite meaningless and
then
um
uh my we happen to have like some some
books by nietzsche and schopenhauer in
the house which you should not read at
age 14
is bad
it's really negative
um
so so but then i then i read
hitchhiker's guide to the galaxy it was
like quite positive i think and um
and it sort of highlighted the the an
important point which is that a lot of
times the question is harder than the
answer and if you can properly phrase
the question then the answer is the easy
part
um and so
uh
the if to agree that we can um better uh
understand the universe then we better
know what questions to ask and
um then whatever the question is that
most approx approximates what's the
meaning of life
you know that that's that's the question
we could ultimately get closer to
understanding
um
and so i thought well to agree that we
can
expand the scope and scale of
consciousness and
knowledge um
human knowledge then that would be a
good thing i think it's also important
to reason from first principles rather
than by analogy so the normal way that
we conduct our lives is we we
we reason by analogy
it's we're doing this because it's like
something else that was done or it's
like what um other people are doing me
too type ideas
yeah it's like
yeah slide iterations on on a theme um
and and uh
and and it's
it because it's it's kind of mentally
easier to reason by analogy rather than
from first principles but by first
principles is kind of a physics way of
looking at the world
and what that really means is
you kind of boil things down to the most
fundamental truths
and and say okay what are we sure is
true or sure as possible is true
and then reason up from there
that takes a lot more mental energy um
give me an example of that like what's
one thing that you've done that on that
you feels worked for you sure so
um somebody could say um in fact people
do uh that battery packs are really
expensive and that's just the way
they'll always be because that's the way
they've been in the past um you're like
well
no that's that's pretty dumb you know
because if if
if you apply that reasoning to
anything new that then
you wouldn't be able to ever
get to that new thing failure and
invention are inseparable twins
um
you know it's
everybody wants to
be inventive you know if you go talk to
corporate america or
any any institution actually
government agencies and so on innovation
is something to be proud of people like
invention
but the problem is they don't like
failure
and you cannot have invention without
failure if you
to know where if you already know it's
going to work it's not an experiment
and only through experimentation can you
get real invention the most important
inventions come from trial and error
with lots of failure and and the failure
is critical
and it's also embarrassing and so that's
why people
in when we're kids
we always are doing trial and error and
we're never embarrassed you know if you
watch a little toddler and they will try
for hours to put a square peg in a round
hole and it never works but doesn't keep
them from trying and they try things
like that and that's how they learn and
uh and
and we all have that when we're little
and then as we get older somehow it's
not as cool
as you get older to fail and to fall
down it looks clumsy
and so we get in our grooves we have a
set of expertise and skills it's kind of
a comfort zone and you have to
constantly push yourself to say no i
don't care about failure in fact if you
know i say at amazon we have to grow the
size of our failures
as the size of our company grows we have
to make bigger and bigger failures
because otherwise none of our failures
will be needle movers and so i would see
it as a very bad sign
over the long run if amazon wasn't
making larger and larger failures and if
you do that all along the way
that is
going to protect you from ever having to
make
that big you know kind of hail mary bet
that you sometimes see
companies make right before they
fail and go out of existence
the most influential people in my life
were my grandparents
and i have a my mother had me when she
was 17 years old
she raised me
with my grandparents help and she was
still in high school when she had me
that was not cool in albuquerque new
mexico in 1964
but she did an incredible job but i was
lucky because i had not just her but i
had she re she married my father when i
was about four years old he has been a
huge influence in my life but my
grandmother and grandfather
were like second set of parents for me
and you learn different things from them
because they're at a different stage of
life and they know different things
they're calm about certain things
it was a huge gift to me my grandfather
was a
had a ranch in texas and i spent all my
summers there from like age 4 to 16 and
he was the most
person
he did all of his own veterinary work
all the things i mean and to observe him
solve problems and figure out how to do
things with no tools and no resources
and you know very small amounts of money
it was a huge education from an early
age so we're very like
one of the things that you i know people
who have
uh they don't have great
family situations and sometimes they
break that cycle and they are the ones
who pull out of it those people are the
ones i reserve my highest admiration for
a great entrepreneurs
should not have a money if you have a
money in your mind this ice is u.s
dollars this is i'm b and you're talking
like english pounds nobody
will work with like
if you have a good dream
if you have a plan to making things
making progress things were happening
and i changed my mind to this morning
just
half an hour there i would do more
things
in africa and the only thing i want to
do is not to sell
products here
and i will enable you to sell your
dreams all over the world in africa
supporting entrepreneurs is always my my
dream because i know how tough it is to
be an entrepreneur
it is difficult
i never cry i said i only make my
competitors cry
because if i cry
i probably die a hundred times
because we have to encourage our team
and i say
making sure that we
that we can survive tomorrow as i said
before i answer a question
i want to say this is my
belief this is what i tell every day to
myself today is difficult
tomorrow is much more difficult but the
day of tomorrow is beautiful most people
die tomorrow evening
even today as my size
for our company's size
i still believe
today is very difficult i have more
problems
than anybody here can imagine
you say ah now you are big you make
billions of dollars every you know
quarter
i have much more problems than you have
people ask me why e-commerce so
successful in china our company alone is
much bigger than amazon
why e-commerce in china
one of the reasons why e-commerce in
china success successful because china
had a terrible infrastructure of
commerce
right we don't have so many retail we
don't have so many like walmart kmart
everywhere
it's it's just a terrible
backward
retail system in china when internet
ecommerce come people love it so so
efficient
why china mobile phone you know grow
much faster than america america and
europe have such a great such a great
system of telephone we don't have 10 of
them
right amount like 100 family can only
have one telephone that days where
mobile come we love that which is the
goal that so there is a leapfrog
we don't have that rules or laws most of
the government offices they don't know
how to make rules laws for internet
because nobody realizes what the
internet look like so that leave us a
chance to grow fast europe
very interesting you have such a perfect
rules loss
then everything you do let's follow the
rules a lot and everything we think
about the thing they do let's follow the
rules a lot and everything we think
about they start to worry when they
worry they make a rules loss
when we have a problems we start to
solve the problems
then think about rules and loss
you have a problem that can make rules a
loss
so
i worry about europe
i worry
i worry about the worries of the europe
if every africa does not worry asia does
not worry why europe worry about
right you don't have the solutions for
artificial intelligence oh you know
they're going to destroy a lot of things
the human life
forget it
let me tell you artificial intelligence
i think
we alibaba using artificial intelligence
to arrest and catch a lot of thieves
my theory i told my engineers i say
now
when you love somebody you may not have
reasons
but when you
hate somebody
you have logic and reasons
we have logic and reasons machine can
always do better than that
so
we have a trillions of dollar
transactions on alipay every day
a lot of people want to steal the money
how can you oversee when you have like a
1 billion users using that there are so
many cheatings
human being cannot do it so we teach
machines to catch all the thieves
machines never forget
no matter how smart you are one person
can create 10 ways of cheating
you are the smartest person in the world
but we teach the machine
every way everything with this discover
from other people the machine can
remember over a hundred thousand ways of
cheating when you start the cheating
machine find you
so
one way
bad guys using artificial intelligence
doing bad things other thing we using
artificial intelligence to catch bad
guys
so there is always in any unbalance
how you see the world if you see
technology revolution is a problem
i'm sorry to say the problem just
started
if you think it's an opportunity
the opportunity just started the only
thing is
your mentality
if the mentality is about a worry you'll
worry all the time
[Applause]
by the way
all the entrepreneurs
if everything's ready
everything's perfect
why they need you
because there is worries because there's
a problems because of there's no this
know that that is your opportunity that
is our opportunity and
keep on that
you believing you can do something
little by little 10 years later you'll
be different that's that's that's who we
are
can you help us understand how to
cultiva how to cultivate that
mindset of being comfortable saying no
being comfortable delegating this is
something that we found with our members
is especially difficult for young women
um and we'd love to just hear your take
on that and maybe any advice you have to
share about that i met bill gates
bill gates in 1991
and when i did it we had a great time
talking he thought he was going to hate
it and i i wasn't too keen on it either
and about 10 hours later we were still
talking but what really got him is when
i pull out this little date book i'm
probably the only guy in the united
states with one of these still what oh
no i have one over there
and i just flipped through it and you
know there's there's probably nothing in
it and bill was really impressed by that
and uh
you've got to keep control of your time
and and you won't keep control of your
time unless you can say no
you can't let other people
set your agenda in life and of course
i know i'm in a very fortunate position
on that because i
i i in another way i'm not so fortunate
because more people ask me for things
and and and then they're usually friends
and they say well can't you just make
this one talk or attend this one
graduation or whatever it may be uh
you know
you you've gotta you just have to
develop the ability to say no and and
and uh do it a few times uh i mean you
know the woman can't say no she's in
trouble right right
right and i mean is this something that
becomes easier over time or how did you
i don't think it's a lot easier no it
it's there's a couple there's a few
things that really just aren't
uncomfortable enough i've the thing i
like the thing i dislike the most the
only thing i really dislike in
connection with my job is that i have to
fire somebody i mean that does not get
easy for
the easier for me as life has gone wrong
and saying no is not like firing people
but it's got a little bit of the same
aspect to it it's not easy to say no
particularly to a friend uh but i will
have every day
three or four or five requests to do
something and i i can't do them all you
know and uh
but i'm not promising it gets easier
but but just keep doing it right
otherwise other people will be running
your life how would you advise people
who aren't necessarily going into a
career field in which you would make a
large base salary such as like medicine
or
something like that maybe
performing arts or
music how would you advise us to
keep up financially with the rest of the
world
well
it is true
that a market system
does not pay as well in some in some
activities as
as might seem appropriate
for the importance of those activities
the society just take teaching for
example i mean teaching does not pay
well
and what could be more important i mean
you know you've got to be as
as interested in who you're
the teachers of your children are as who
your accountant is or you know whatever
or who's winning the heavyweight title
of the world or that sort of thing but
but it doesn't it doesn't pay well and
and
it's a fundamental choice
uh whether you're going to go into
something that for many people it'd be a
fundamental choice whether you're going
to go into something you love or
something to to try and make a lot of
money i think that
generally it pays to go with what you
love
i think that
it's very hard to find people
when they get to be my age
who say they're on that they've loved
what they've done all their life and
feel was very worthwhile
uh but they're terribly sad they made
that choice because they didn't make a
lot of money i i don't think anybody's
ever
ever said that to me that they wish
they'd gone into something else where
they were uncomfortable doing it or
didn't enjoy it didn't feel very
productive but made a lot of money so i
don't think you'll find
that so i would i would i would go to
work
i would go to work
in whatever turns you on
it may turn out that it'll it'll be more
profitable than than you can think but
almost everybody here will make
enough money unless they get some
terrible habits along the way
to do reasonably well and and doing
reasonably well in this country
really is
is uh is pretty darn good i mean
it is
it's not necessary to have
uh huge amounts of money in order enjoy
yourself i enjoyed myself when i was at
my ten thousand dollars and i live in
the same house that i lived in when i
was making when i had about that i
bought it 41 years ago i like the house
then i like the house now
i mean
if you think about it
if you have a reasonable job
you'll be eating at mcdonald's and i'll
be eating mcdonald's so we're we're to
push on on on food i mean you know in
fact i hope it's dairy queen actually in
may
and if you come to dairy queen you'll
see me and you can order anything on the
menu i can order we both can afford it
uh
you know you'll you'll wear the same
clothes i wear i'll pay more for my
suits but as soon as i put them on they
look cheap on me so we'll look about the
same and
um
we'll both live in the same kind of
houses i live in that house from 41
years ago and it's it's it's warm in
winter and it's cool in summer and it's
comfortable
and you'll live in a house that's that's
similar and then and what difference
does it make it if you have 50 more
rooms or you know guest houses or all
that
you know it'll probably just bring you
problems i mean you have to worry about
the about the greenskeeper or something
when you get through so i i i have been
in the houses of people
where the houses are worth
[Music]
oh probably 200 times
what my house is worth and i would not
be any happier in those houses at all in
fact i'd be less happy i just have one
more thing to
to worry about and you know the
dozens of people around the place and
people quitting and people stealing from
you and all kinds of things to hell with
it yeah uh
we drive we'll drive the same kind of
car in fact you'll probably drive a
better car i drive a car's about eight
years old i don't know what it's worth
now but it gets me around fine i mean
i'm perfectly happy we'll watch
we'll watch the same television you know
we'll work on the same computer pretty
much the only difference will be
how we travel long distances you know
i will
fly in a plane that's
more comfortable than
than flying southwest airlines or
something which i've got nothing against
but that's the one real big difference
and other than that i do what i like
every day i hope you you'll do what you
like every day to do and i work with
nice people i hope you work with nice
people uh
and there's 24 hours in the day and
those are where the hours go so
great wealth
uh
is
the tiniest bit different
in a real sense than having just a
decent
a decent income and
and to trade a decent income
and something you love doing and
something where you feel worthwhile
doing it
for
huge wealth where you trade off a lot of
your principles
uh would be a terrible mistake
recently you shared in a press
conference
that one of facebook's focuses for the
next decade
is that it is more important to be
understood
than be liked
will you just share what you meant by
that
yeah i mean
look it's
let's be real here i'm not i'm not like
communicating is not my best thing right
um
you know i came out here i've
been planning for this i'm excited about
it and then i messed up the name of our
data center within 30 seconds
so i mean look when when i got started
with facebook i was 19.
and um and i there were so many parts
about building a company that i didn't
know right i didn't i didn't know
anything about hiring or managing or
building a company and i certainly
didn't
really know that much about you know how
to
communicate about what we were doing
with the world i'm an engineer by
training right i
i love coding i like building products
that's that's kind of the background
um
and
you know my experience you know kind of
growing up and running the company is
you know went out talked about what we
did
say some stupid things get called out
for it and get like kind of go into a
into a shell right and and uh end up
being really cautious about how we
communicate
so
you know it kind of it worked out okay
for a while for the company because
we we built products that a lot of
people really like and you know we
weren't winning because we were
communicating well we were winning
because the products were working well i
think in spite of the fact that we were
communicating quite poorly about what we
were doing but broadly speaking for a
long time uh the basic approach was okay
let's try to not like
do anything that's going to be too
offensive right and and we'll kind of
explain what we're doing in broad
strokes and talk about the mission of
what we're doing which is something that
i really believe in helping to build
community and and bring people closer
together
but you know i think we just shied away
for a long time talking about some of
the things that
some of the principles that we believe
in that that
that are increasingly controversial in
the world and
i just think that we
for one don't have that luxury anymore
for two uh i i think that that kind of
led for a while to a sentiment towards
the company that was
positive but fairly shallow because if
people if if you're not kind of out
there standing for things that uh that
people care about then you know it's not
possible for people to feel that
strongly about what you're doing but so
now you know i i've just i've tried to
change our approach more recently you
know i went out and i in georgetown
last year i gave this speech around our
principles around free expression
and you know that's just one of the
areas that i really feel like is under
attack right now so what what do you
think the three keys to your success are
well i think a lot of it goes back to
those values right i mean the values
often come from the founder the person
running the company so i think i believe
those things probably the most strongly
of people at the company
um yeah move fast be bold right um focus
on impact and i think um
you know i think long-term focus is a
really important part of this and we've
had a lot of opportunities to optimize
for the shorter term whether it's in
selling the company or doing different
products that would have benefited us in
the short term but not optimized for the
long-term impact then um
and i just think you know opportunities
like this don't come around that often
so when you get one i feel like you
almost have a duty to see it through and
build it to be what it can be is spanx
started way before i cut the feet out of
my pantyhose that's the sound bite in
the press that everybody's talked about
for almost 20 years but it actually
started
fundamentally on
when i was 16 i worked on mindset for
myself and i'm such a believer in
mindset is almost everything and it just
happened to be a a set of circumstances
i was riding my bike with one of my best
friends at 16 and she was run over by a
car and killed in front of me
and then a few months later my dad left
home and my parents separated and
ultimately got divorced and when my dad
moved out he came into my bedroom and he
handed me a cassette tape series called
how to be a no limit person by wayne
dyer
and he said sweetie i wish i discovered
this when i was your age instead of the
age of 40. and then he moved out
and so i started listening to this how
to be a no limit person which was
talking about visualization law of
attraction
not caring about what other people think
about you the fear you know not being
consumed by the fear of failure and it
just the clouds parted for me and i
thought you know i've spent a lot of
time being taught what to think but no
one's really teaching me how to think
and at 16 that was so incredibly
important so in this digital platform
it's kind of passing on a lot of these
insights that deal with mindset that i
think is the real reason that spanx
exists
the packaging what am i going to do for
the packaging i knew i thought as a
consumer i didn't know anything else i'd
never actually taken a marketing class
either in my life but i knew as a
consumer i was frustrated i was going
into the hosiery departments and
everything looked the same it was the
same beige package or the same way
package with the same half-naked woman
that had been on there for 30 years
and
i couldn't tell what i was buying so i
said to myself i'm going to do this
different i want it to be my favorite
color red
no one had ever done red in the hosiery
space before i wanted to be bold stand
out i knew that if i got a chance to be
on the shelf with no money to advertise
it had to jump out and say i'm new i'm
different try me so i put three animated
illustrated cartoon women on the package
which had also never been done before
there had only ever been photography on
these poetry packages i was working on
it every night after work on my friend's
computer she had just finished
graphic design school so i would come
home and we would sit side by side and i
was cutting out lips and eyes and i was
very you know excited about how to make
it design wise i wanted it to feel like
you were buying a present for yourself
instead of a commodity that we dreaded
people often ask me
what it takes to start a business what
was the key ingredient how about how do
i start the business and how did we grow
to about 20 million
20 million dollars in sales so quickly
you know they all come up with some new
whiz-bang idea they're going to
they're going to come up with new
software new hardware and more often
than not it seems like they spent their
millions before they thought through
their idea
but when we talk about good companies
and growth and success there really is
only one common ingredient across any
type of business whether it's oil or
computers or soft or anything and that
key ingredient is customers
without customers whether you're
starting a business running a business
expanding a business you don't have a
business
there is no business
customers are the key ingredient you get
those profits
you got to have the customers
and you got to have happy customers
that's the bottom line
you know microsolution keeping we've
been going and growing and it's
impossible not to have growing pains
it's impossible not to make mistakes we
screw up all the time
and you know it doesn't bother me as
president if i have
you just didn't do something right just
made a mistake
it's good
because if you're not making mistakes
you're not trying hard enough you know
these things i'm saying they're not
unique they're not things that i just
thought up in some some miracle bro
you know things when i talk to people in
our company when i talk to people about
our company i never have unique thought
i can't remember i don't know that i
ever did i can't remember if i ever will
or i don't expect ever to
there's no magic formulas to customer
service there's no magic formula to
doing things right these these sayings
that you hear me say are things that
i've read elsewhere and just regurgitate
that
but how many people do that
you know we all know the golden rule
do unto others as you would have them do
unto you
and that's nice
you know
but do you do it
but even more importantly than your role
what about the lover's role
do on others as you would love to have
them do unto you
that's what we try to stress at micro
solutions that's what we try to use to
differentiate ourselves
not just to get by because everybody's
going to be nice
you know when you invite someone into
your house that
is an acquaintance that you liked okay
you're going to offer
you're going to offer them a donut and
that's really what you expect you know
if you went to their house because
you're just acquaintances
but when you leave their house
it was nice
if you go to that fine if you don't go
back fine that's the way customers look
at businesses
if i go better fine if i don't go back
fine
you know they say that 80 of the people
who have a problem tell at least 10
people
only 10 of the people who had a good
experience tell anybody
and it's the same way when you go to
visit an acquaintance
and when people come to try to do
business with microsolution i hope i
pray and i try to convey to each and
every one of our people
that we give them a reason
to want to come back
we give them a reason to do a good
morning rap to say okay let's do
business with micro solutions
you've got to really concentrate to do
unto others as you would love to have
them do it to you even after you had
done your thing there was still an
eighth course to make sure that yahoo
itself was on track do you know what
that was about yeah they were screwing
everything up you know i mean look they
had they had an opportunity to dominate
um streaming media they also owned at
the same time the patent to cost per
click yeah
right now
google's entire business to this day
is built around
pay-per-click rather they're not called
pay-per-click yeah
so they had the entire patent for
pay-per-click
had they just said sorry google
you can't use it
there would be no google
instead they said yeah 133 million
dollars and give us some stock
they were just too nice
right which blinded them in a lot of
respects and i remember walking in with
a 32 million dollar sale
saying okay we're going to do streaming
we're going to sell all this company's
content you know it's worth 32 million
dollars for us and it's going to pre-up
these other
potential competitors
and um
i forget it was jerry or tim whoever
said no
we don't work that way we don't preempt
competition we just leave it open
i'm like okay it's time for me to go buy
a basketball team
that's they just they just didn't see
these things and i mean it's a lesson in
your businesses there's going to be
everybody's always trying to kick your
ass
and you have to figure out how to kick
your out your own ass first
seriously because if you're not brutally
honest with yourself and your own
business about what your frailties are
someone else is going to find them yahoo
didn't get that yahoo just thought you
know what we're just going to continue
moving forward and we'll just compete
with everybody else and you know there's
we have no other problems
didn't quite work out for them did it i
think when dreams start to brew in us or
when there's like a seed planted in us
where we have this dream it kind of
started that way where i was like like
it was like a little inkling like wait a
minute if i if i could figure out how to
launch how to create a product that
works for me i better help a lot of
other people and then i would kind of
like silence that dream and i would my
head would take over oh jamie you have
no connections you have barely any money
you don't know anything about the beauty
industry
and you're you're in your dream job
right now right and so it was i went
through that battle and i think everyone
listening to us right now probably like
really if they get still they probably
know right now
if there's a dream on their heart or or
something they know
or they're supposed to create or go
after or offer the world or start
painting again or start dancing right
they kind of know
um but sometimes our head talks
ourselves out of our lives absolutely
dreams the fastest way to grow a
business is to collaborate with other
people is to find uh these fairies that
are going back and forth b-roll okay uh
the fairies uh dude i mean i could build
a boat or i could just go right on one
of those exactly right and
what what we're doing today is we are
drafting or just collaborating with yeah
um
cardone capital
i don't go build apartments no i buy
apartments that are already built
that way i can scale faster if i was
trying to do the building thing now now
construction
teams right
um
now along the way i'm fixing i'm
adjusting as i go okay but but i need to
get in the water and start swimming in
some direction i think too many people
are trying to figure out where they're
going yeah
and by the time you figure it out
somebody's already there what would be
um
a few non-negotiables that everyone
should take with their money like if
okay if you don't if you've got a
hundred thousand you want to get to a
million you've got a million went to 10.
pay attention to it okay pay attention
you should look at your money every day
look at it every day look at the bank
account look at the bank account how
many what are your cash accounts and
what are your investments
look at it every day every single day it
takes what is that five seconds what
does that do for you where am i
inventory
personal inventory mm-hmm so where am i
it's measurable you can see it if it's
zero look at it until it makes you sick
okay and then you see some money sitting
in a bank okay you got 100 grand sitting
in a bank account or 50 grand okay you
need look look what's what is it earning
people are unconscious they don't know
where their money is
this is the scam on on on this planet
you give money you work your ass off and
then you give it to an institution and
you forget that it's there wells fargo
is paying you nothing bank of america is
paying you nothing
you send it to chase they're not paying
you anything
you send it to to the mutual fund you
don't even know what it's invested in
it's invested in stuff you don't even
believe in right it's invested in war
stocks tobacco stocks drug companies
like you that's not things you even
believe in like like people have their
money like
that's that's not even
conducive with the things they believe
in in their life yeah
so um
you know if you don't drink alcohol why
would you invest your money in alcohol
stocks true
so so pay attention to where the money
is what is it paying you where is it
look at it every day it takes literally
two minutes or less
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below
on this video i will showcase you and
celebrate you somewhere on the screen in
a future video because
you are awesome if you want seven more
amazing insights into how billionaires
think check the video right there next
to me i think you'll love it continue to
believe and i'll see you there i became
terrified of public speaking and uh i
just couldn't do it we don't love this
product but we think others will love it
you know that's not really how it works
if you don't love it don't expect others
will either